hey everyone and welcome to a special
episode of console crew slash generation
next whatever you want to call it uh
we're gonna be looking back on our first
year with the xbox series x and s and
look at the year that was celebrate talk
about things that microsoft needs to do
for the second year of its new console
uh to join me and help talk through it
all i've got xbox expert jordan romain
yo
and playstation pro tomorrow saying
absolutely pitching a tent to be back
lads they thought we were gone about
this
[Laughter]
still a threat
let's kick off by talking about the
actual consoles themselves uh we'll go
around the room what does everyone have
jordan what do you have
xbox x always x uh
yeah i mean i'm i'm probably the only
guy at gamespot who like uses their xbox
like every single day but yeah that's
just me
that's just me tim what do you have
absolutely vibrating to tell you what
i've got lads uh i've got a xbox series
x and an xbox series s which should tell
you a lot about how i feel the xbox uh
performance has been for this generation
so far so nice i bought it twice
have you taken your xbox series s out of
the box yet no
okay i have an xbox series x
i uh so
let's let's get like i want to know how
much you guys use it so i use mine
quite a lot um i still think i have more
of a balance on when it comes to
third-party stuff especially i kind of
balance it out both ways i've used uh my
series x absolutely is a game pass
machine and kind of mopping up stuff um
over this last year more than anything
we'll talk about kind of game releases
and stuff um in a little bit and i use
it mostly as kind of i use
i use in my netflix machine as well
quite a lot so i get a nice amount of
use out of it but i would say that it's
it's way more balanced i would say than
how i was going between xbox and
playstation last gen last gen was like
playstation 4 for everything and xbox
was on occasionally so now i feel like
i've got a good balance jordan what do
you do pretty much every single day i'm
turning on my xbox like i think the only
days that i'm not turning on the xbox
are
days where it's like oh it's my mom's
birthday i should go like do something
with her instead of i think i played
video games today i thought you're gonna
say it's my mom's birthday i'm gonna
play the playstation 5 today
i'm so worried like total tangent but
i'm like so worried like halo infinite
comes out on my birthday and i know my
family and friends are gonna be like yo
jordan it's your birthday we should do
something i'll be like i don't want to
do anything this is what i want you i
want to stay home and play halo um but
yeah like i i play the xbox practically
every day which is very similar to my
xbox one
habits um it's
my playstation 5 and switch are like for
their first party or their console
exclusives and xbox for practically
everything else yeah i mean um i will
say the xbox 360 still stands as the
most played xbox console for me however
i
i don't think i play my xbox as much as
i play the playstation or
the pc um or
switch less so but um
certainly more than the xbox one however
i feel like i'm still engaging with the
xbox ecosystem and i think the reason
that i'm not playing the xbox
specifically is because those games are
accessible in so many different ways now
which we'll come to later um i'm playing
xbox games
a lot i'm just not specifically playing
them on the xbox series xls console
right now
i mean that's what big phil likes to
hear phil loves what he wants big phil
loves that he's like somewhere over
there it's like tickling him like his
asm in his ear he's like
he's engaged in the ecosystem well
that's that's a good enough segway i
think to discuss kind of the surrounding
bit we'll talk about games and game pass
like i said in a second but um this this
first year i feel has been you know just
the fact that xcloud is open to everyone
with a game pass sub has genuinely
changed the way that i play games a lot
which is weird because we're here
talking about first year with the series
xns and yet like this is a cloud thing
that i was using i was playing yakuza
like a dragon i was like showing to my
showing to my dad i was like oh remember
when we had a computer that wouldn't
even run worms while i'm playing a
triple a
jrpg here on my phone he couldn't care
less but
you know my console was hundreds of
miles away and i could still play those
games
back up you know when i went to visit my
parents and stuff and so
i'm
just so pleasantly surprised and like
you said it's like i'm
interacting with the xbox ecosystem in
so many different ways than i didn't
anticipate that i would
yeah i think like game pass is
a best-in-class service for game like
there's nothing we talked about this
plenty before it came out and before the
xbox came out and why it is now like
it's just come leaps and bounds where
it feels like whether it's true or not
it feels like you're actively losing
money if you're not subscribed to it
which is a wild place to be like it is
like
if you have an xbox and you don't have
game pass subscription what are you
doing with your life like that is you're
leaving money on the table and the fact
that you can not only
pay to be in the service where you get a
a steady drip feed of good games um but
also you can access them in so many
specific or so many different ways and
you can do that remotely or on other
platforms like the pc
it's just
an unbelievably uh masterfully executed
um
service based on the vision that they
put out there when they came out and
they said they were going to do this we
were like yeah we'll see and not only
have they done it i think they've done
it
better than any of us could have
predicted i don't think it's there yet
entirely it's not like this is done now
and this is where it is and i think
microsoft knows that and they're
actively working to improve it but
every single day every improvement every
change on game pass makes it better it's
never taken a step back as far as i know
and the baseline if you jumped in today
like i would wholeheartedly recommend it
um it's just an excellent service
they're making gaming like so
accessible to like so many people who
couldn't like oh i can't afford the new
500 console or i can't afford to buy
five different games in a year and hope
that i'm able to play
all of them like i just i need to
be able to try certain games i need to
be able to play games in places where
it's like i i just can't get access to
the new xbox series x and it's so
cool and i wish a lot more people were
doing what xbox and microsoft were doing
to make gaming more approachable and
more accessible to so many people
especially with game pass and xcloud and
just everything that they're doing yeah
and and kind of like the
the thing i love about it is the spirit
of live arcade is back in it like it's
it's it lives in there again like you
know you can right now go on and play
what is it unpacking you can play
uh is it unsighted for example is that
what's called unsighted answer yeah
yeah like these indie games that are
amazing but
you know aren't getting as much
attention as they deserve they are
available to play on on game pass i
think the one area of um improvement
that i would love to see is better
spotlighting and maybe even playlisting
yes and like yeah spotify does this
great thing where it's like hey you've
played this game based on your tastes
you know this you should try this out or
your friends are doing this your friends
are playing this game maybe you should
check it out to be part of the
conversation i would love that because
and it's only because game pass has
grown to a place where it is difficult
to find things now um and netflix had
that issue where it was like all right
we've got so much stuff on here now that
it's hard to find stuff so if they were
better about curating that and
presenting it to people it could be
great but like i said that's just a
bonus and i'm sure they'll get there
eventually um how are you finding so
given the abundance of games that are
available on game pass how are you
finding your memory
storage have you had to upgrade yet
i haven't yet yet no it's one terabyte
like this but that's the thing i mean
there is you know there is a pro tip for
for managing and and ensuring that you
never reach in a situation where you're
you're having to contend with space and
that tip is
don't download call of duty
that's the thing why would i ever
download call of duty i mean
i'm literally downloading call of duty
right now so
don't hurt me but no i mean i i think
you know not to do a kind of comparison
but like
to do a comparison you know having been
gaming on the xbox and bing gaming on
the playstation the fact that i can't
run you know my playstation 5 games from
external hard drive the fact that it is
harder for me to get an expansion of my
storage there
does suck especially when yes the
seagate drive is expensive but you
literally just you just plug it in and
it's right there and also expandable
storage um
on the xbox is just
so much easier i haven't had to use it
just yet but the fact that i know that
if i did have to it's so much easier
yes it's a huge cost on both on both
platforms but like i don't have to take
my xbox apart to put extra storage in
yeah just plug it in is obviously
something that is um
i'm way more interested in doing this
xbox definitely has the bonus or the
advantage of availability and ironically
it's the the proprietary nature of that
expandable hard drive that makes it more
available whereas you know the hard
drives for the playstation side um or
the expandable memory for the
playstation side is still quite tricky
to get and it's also
it is a lot of uh high cost um
but yeah i i haven't reached a point
where i needed it and i you know the
call of duty thing was a joke
but also is
kind of true is it though
it is kind of true i mean the latest
call of duty is a little better
optimized so it doesn't take as much
space or vanguard is in a better
situation but if you're downloading like
warzone modern warfare and war zone are
huge they are massive like unreasonably
large like and that is one of the main
reasons i don't play those games because
i'm like i've no i'm not i've got i can
fit in four games in the space that you
take and uh like whenever i play you i
get off the
the plane and then just immediately get
shot by some
sweaty teenager
halfway across the map yeah from the
other side of the map like see me on pc
then we'll talk
um um one thing i wanted to discuss
though while we're talking kind of like
about the consoles and the tech aspect i
did want to talk about quick resume but
also the introduction of dolby atmos and
dobby vision um i don't think my tv is
good enough and certainly my sound bar
is not good enough to really experience
like the full element of it obviously
there is going to be the big jump in in
graphics and speed and and you know even
audio
on next-gen current gen it's current gen
now uh on xbox series x and playstation
5. um and so that's the kind of thing
that is a kind of investment for me i
suppose to fully be able to experience
it because i don't have the xbox headset
just yet either i know that has dolby um
and so you've got to get the headset
lucy well so good so i saw it i saw it
in target the other day
ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen
i saw it and i was like i've just moved
i don't need it but then kind of looking
into it and seeing how much everyone
loves them like it was also the last one
and i should have just bought it um
but the thing that has really impressed
me like the big thing that i think i've
taken
i take certainly take for granted
especially when i compare it with my
experience playing a playstation which
is quick resume is
and i'm using the phrase game changer
but it's amazing and the fact that
it's more of a game swapper than a game
changer if you know what i'm saying
you do technically change games though
push glasses up nose but the thing the
thing that gets me about it is like my
um we had a power cut
and
my xbox games were still fine
like they were still in suspended in the
same state that i left them in i didn't
lose any progress uh evan this is where
you put the i lived [ __ ] meme
we had a power cut it was like no it was
like the lights flick it off for like
five minutes they came back on but also
just being able to kind of
you know have a bunch of stuff
downloaded um like for some reason i
thought earlier in the year that i
wanted to play fallout new vegas and
skyrim and so i downloaded them both
from game pass and then i was kind of
piggybacking that with i think gears or
something and i was like yes this is
this is how i want to be i can just go
gears and then quickly go to this then
quickly go to that and it just and then
maybe i'll go to netflix or something
but it's like kind of extremely chaotic
gaming experience that you create for
yourself
you know
i i think
that was
absolutely mad like i i have that thing
but it's like i'll do like oh i'm gonna
have i did download skyrim to play it
and i started it but then i swapped over
to like
an indie game not like i'm gonna do
skyrim and then fall out new vegas and
then i'm gonna play netflix
do you do you think throw a little gta
in there do you think there's anyone do
i constantly feel overwhelmed do you
because i feel like i do it it's the
fact that it's two like very different
bethesda rpgs so your brain is very
gonna be very confused as to what's
going on like fantasy
post-apocalyptic yeah and then i mean
if he was in skyrim he would be the
thing that connects them all but anyway
so i find i find quick resume so so
impressive and i love it is there
anything in particular
tech wise peripheral wise
um from the two of you that has you've
really highlighted the use of in the
last year jordan will come to you yeah i
i'm i'm not sure if this is like more a
promotion of the xbox versus like a dig
towards other people but going into this
generation when xbox was talking about
like how fast everything was going to
load and how everything was going to
look so pretty with just how much more
powerful the series x and s were going
to be i was like i don't really care
about this like i don't care waiting
like 20 to 30 seconds on load times and
yet now like playing that for
a year now it gets to the point where
sometimes i
open something like my switch and like
the game takes 15 seconds to go through
a loading screen i'm like why is this
taking so long it's still taking way too
long stops you doom scrolling that's the
thing
i get i guess yeah so it is important
but it's like one of those crazy things
like that quick resume like xbox was
talking about a whole bunch of things
that i think a lot of people like me
were like i i don't see how this matters
in terms of just like we just want good
games to play on xbox and yet there's
such excellent quality of life things
that make
other pieces of hardware seem less
appealing than xbox i'm like oh this is
clever this was a really cool thing to
like try to get ahead of to
subconsciously plant the idea that like
xbox is the ideal place to play
third-party games i've been using my
elite controller finally way more i
bought that in the in the uh xbox one
era and i never used it for that it's
not even one it's so good and now like
i've used it on and like i love the dual
sense as well i think the dual sensor is
a great controller but when you pick up
that that the elite two i'm just like
oh this is tasty this hits different
this hit's different and truly like i i
love that and it's one of those things
where
you feel good about you feel excited to
play games when you're when you pick up
and turn on an xbox and i have a lot of
that um
on the playstation 5 as well but it's
not always just from picking up the
controller but when i pick up the
controller i'm like this is good and um
i think the uh the actual in terms of
the operating system has come a long way
my biggest gripes with the xbox are
still quite a bit focused on the
operating system but i'm i'm very
surprised at how they took that that
hot mess of an os for the xbox one and
have like really beat it into some sort
of usable shape now it's like i said
it's not the best still it's still kind
of confusing in ways and i do
occasionally find myself just being like
where the hell is this thing and why
can't i find it um but still it's way
more usable it's way more customizable
and i think the good thing that they did
was they they kind of broke out the
restrictions to be like let's just make
it so people can put the things that
they need or know they're gonna access
most front and center and then the rest
of that can be a like a complete
catastrophe off on the sides and they
don't ever have to look at it and engage
with it which i appreciate a lot well
you don't miss the connect on xbox one
and using your hand and voicings
i did that approximately one time and i
was like this is terrible
we managed to go that whole section
without really discussing the kind of
year of game releases that xbox has had
and i will say in terms of exclusives
it's not exactly been you know
banger after banger to bang it or at
least like what they have released has
been great but there haven't been that
many of them so obviously we had flight
sim forza horizon 5. um things like
psychonauts are all like exceptional
games um but they feel like they've been
few and far between um artful escape is
in there too um
an age of empires on pc but it's like it
feels like xbox has been really building
and they've had these great showcases
obviously they had one where they
had bethesda on and they talked that
starfield would be on not only on game
pass but it'd be xbox exclusive and pc
um
and so it feels like they're really
building and kind of c holding onto that
momentum but
that's up until recordings that's the
first year of the console because halo
halo
is right there yes i can i can taste it
solid kickoff to year two yeah seriously
um what do you think
we hope that's true it might no it might
be we've been bound before all over
again
i mean all signs point to something good
but we've been burned before lock i'm
looking at you
um so what do you think about like the
the first year of xbox
ex let's we'll talk about exclusives
then we'll get on a game pass but
i i don't think it's been the strongest
strongest lineup it's been you know
a few information i would i would agree
because like for first party it was
psychonauts 2 and 4 is a horizon 5.
and then honestly i think they're
like some of their stronger console
exclusives were the ones that were like
limited time like death's door and the
medium
um
but they had like some
stinkers in there too like 12 minutes
that we really don't need to talk about
how day you bring them
but yeah like it was definitely one of
those where i'm like oh this kind of
feels like an xbox one year for lack of
a better term where there's like oh
there's like two like solid exclusives
that i was looking forward to that i'm
really enjoying but i'm like looking at
the promises that xbox has and hoping
that you know year two is
better like they have
four
first party games scheduled for
the second year of the series x life
cycle and i don't think that only two of
them are going to make it but like year
two at least looks better than year one
yeah yeah they've been i feel like you
the approach that they have taken is
like sowing the seeds for a banger over
the next couple years which is
by way of acquisitions and and kind of
like snapping up games are actively in
development and ensuring that they have
a comfortable home and make sure making
sure that the messaging is out there far
and wide that this is the place that
you're going to be able to play them
i mean like they've got arcane locked
down they've got bethesda's all of their
other studios locked down they're making
you know uh their own first party titles
between perfect dark and
and a bunch of others uh fable um
hellboat 2. hellblade 2 yeah so they did
a lot of lot of hard work on
very quickly turning themselves into a
a company that has
the power
to
put out titles that
kind of rival playstation in terms of
first party output i'm not saying in
terms of quality that remains to be seen
um but at the very least they've got
you know they've got uh companies that
they can bring to the table and be like
these are these are gonna be bangers or
these are gonna these are high profile
and that is important and in the
meantime they've kind of leaned they've
they've kind of made the most of that
situation by leaning heavily on game
pass
creating um partnerships like
the idea of having death door there for
a little while as an exclusive like you
can't underestimate or undersell how
important stuff like that is 12 minutes
yes a stinker um from us some people
like it uh our own reviewer liked it um
but the important thing was for a period
of time that was the big the
conversation around that was you know
excitement um and xbox is where you play
that uh so
in that regard it was a success for them
um and then kind of bringing in uh games
that they feel are popular and could
find a second wind get a second wind on
game pass like um avengers or you know
supporting sea of thieves and that kind
of stuff back for blood but i mean even
even outriders which was a game by all
accounts had very very minimal bars
and then as soon as it was announced
that it was going on game pass just like
interest shut up and yes sure i'll try
it yeah that's the thing it gives you
the um the ability to try it and yes
interest died on that game
a few weeks after it launched
unfortunately but like it did get it
give it that peak and that kind of bump
in the in the public consciousness and
i'm very intrigued to see what's going
to happen with avengers
um
but i wonder if that one's just maybe
just
i mean
the story of xbox when it comes to
software is
sure you may not have had exclusives but
you certainly weren't starved of new
gaming experiences you had that was
plentiful you had plenty of that um so
you know if you're an xbox owner like uh
we are like i i felt no i didn't feel
slighted i didn't feel underserved i
felt good about everything that was
going on in the xbox ecosystem yeah um
it was good
and especially and especially stuff like
the big big updates coming to
uh games as a service that they already
have and especially the ones that are on
game pass like the huge uh cap jack
sparrow uh content pack that they had
for sea of thieves this year the
constant updates that game gets and i
imagine that you know things like
grounded will continue to get that
support and as well as there are other
games like forza which i'm very excited
to play and it's the fact that it's on
game person yeah like okay yeah and if
it wasn't for forza i would be a i think
i'd be a little bit more negative than
what the two of you are right now
because like without forza like xbox
goes the entire
first year of this new console without
like
a solid
like a solid banger that you can like
look at and you're like this is the game
that you can play on
xbox and like xbox didn't really have
that in my opinion yeah it's like till
forza so nothing like no shade at all to
games like awful escape or psychonauts 2
but they are not necessarily system
sellers no they're not ratcheting clank
they're not spider-man they're not demon
souls they're not like games i look at
them like yo i want to play this game on
next gen right now
i will say one of the things that i feel
like xbox needs some
credit for is they've been very savvy in
taking the temperature of the culture
and reacting to it with their
experiences like this was the year when
um they i mean like it's been happening
for a long time
within smaller you know communities like
ours like they looked around and they
saw the momentum was building on a
franchise like yakuza they were like oh
people are very into yakuza right now
and
they
you know put in the work to make all of
those games available on xbox game pass
and that is like massive and they've
repeatedly done that where they've
looked at the environment they've looked
at what people are talking about and
they've gone how can we make this how
can we be part of this conversation and
like
seeing knowing that there's a decent
chance of you you seeing a conversation
about a game happening on twitter and
then going to game pass and seeing the
games already there or knowing that give
it a little while and those games will
show up was incredibly valuable to
ensure that the kind of from a
conversational and pr perspective there
was always some sort of positive
discussion point amidst the lack of a
you know a breakout first party
exclusive so i think they've been
they've done a very interesting
job of one making sure that the
conversation always had some positive
element of it and two
like socially through their marketing
and through their social teams always
being
part of the conversation and being
positive around it and engaging with
things and never being you know
competitive so it's a very wholesome and
very kind of
self-celebratory
um uh ecosystem or like a position that
xbox has worked their way into and
that's impressive i think yeah i
completely agree i think they're um
i don't know they always seem it seems
like more personable yeah xbox like
certainly and you know they kind of lean
into their own memes they release you
know they they double down on craig and
halo and they release
xbox fridges and shoes and
you know it it feels like i don't know
it's it's
you can't say this about like a massive
conglomerate but you know it definitely
feels like more
personable um but obviously people work
there and you know make it make you know
want to be
friendly and a big film everything big
phil yeah
so
what do we need
to see change like what what are we
looking forward to in the year two of
the xbox series x and s and what are
like the big things that need to change
that's a big question
um jordan i'll come to you we just need
i don't know it maybe this is like more
so for me because i'm like one of those
people that like i saw all the yakuza
games coming to game pass and i'm like
this is really cool and xbox is gonna
get props for this but this is also
something that i'm like i don't care
about this if i wanted to play yakuza i
would have played yakuza
years ago on playstation um and
i i'm sorry tim i didn't hear about
anyone who was like oh i went through
and i played through all the yaksa games
on game pass if anything i think the pr
son of just releasing them on game pass
did more for xbox than actually
putting them there i mean i really like
them on that so uh the point is is the
fact that
xbox is this really cool ecosystem that
i'm happy to be there but i still i have
no idea where the ecosystem is
going they say like oh game pass is
going to be this hyper curated list of
like a hundred plus games that people
are going to have plus first party
titles but now it's like a list of 300
plus games if you add like everything
from the console and pc side plus ea
play and it's hard to find like that
curated list that they had anymore
they're like oh we bought bethesda and a
bunch of other like studios and we have
all these games coming out but
obviously like they're so far away that
we only have
dates for like two of them and like
loose time frames or like two more and
i'm like xbox has all these great ideas
and positive vibes and i love them but i
have no
idea where they're trying to take me and
like the exact like message that they're
trying to deliver me and so i just in
2022 i just like even it's like hey
you're not getting these things until
2023 2024 like just
some sort of idea as to a road map of
like when we're getting certain games
what their overall plan is for game pass
besides just making it a netflix style
of a huge amount of titles like what's
what's going on what are you doing with
this ecosystem that you've never
developed and people are invested but
it's just remaining stagnant and it's
not evolving
into anything i just i want some
clarification there yeah i think i i
agree on a lot of what jordan said there
like the everything that we've said is
undoubtedly positive but also
it also creates this kind of i feel like
they need something to unify their
vision a little more um or at least
restate their vision in a way that makes
sense to a lot of people to grasp
because
for everything that they have given us
that we've reacted positively it's a new
piece of a puzzle that we're not still
really sure what the picture is
presenting us
um there's the the kind of cloud stuff
there's
game pass and the lack of curation there
there's
uncertainty around when games from their
new first party studios are going to be
available like
the stuff around hellblade 2 for example
is like
deeply confusing at times where you know
they show it off and then the stuff
they're showing off seems very early in
development and you're like so when are
we going to be able to play this stuff
and it's a product of like
using these announcements to get people
excited about it but they're not telling
us enough of when they will actually be
able to
you know
realize the excitement that they have
felt for those games so you know stuff
like we saw red fall but we don't know
when red falls going to be available so
it's just like this floating lingering
thing in the air and it kind of reminds
me a lot of uh it's a weird comparison
draw but it kind of reminds me a lot of
way the square enix and
crystal dynamics dealt with avengers
where they were like
yeah we have this content we have this
thing this thing and then they didn't
give us a road map so we were like what
the hell's going on when where is this
stuff where is that raid where like
where is spider-man and
it just lets people it
the more you leave it hanging the more
frustrating it becomes i think that
microsoft definitely has it in them to
i definitely think they're self-aware
enough to know that is the case and i
suspect that they might have that in the
plans once they have a better idea
themselves maybe even as soon as
something like you know game awards they
could talk about it um though i suspect
gamers are more focused on um
just showing off trailers i really think
that they need a kind of state of xbox
kind of thing that is like a a kind of
on its own doesn't have to be
you know tied to a specific event that
they usually would do like x whatever
the latest one is called um
but like they need to sit down and be
like fireside chat with big phil get
paris lily back on it like have him ask
the questions whatever um but i think
that's an important thing to for them to
do just help create that clarity and
give us some sort of roadmap to get
excited about because things are a bit
of a jumble
um on a more nitty gritty scale i
earlier said that the uh the os is
working good now i still think that they
should build something a little more
uh streamlined and a little more focused
on it it's the one part of the xbox
experience that i still feel like is
holding it back and dating it in a way
um and kind of making it feel a bit
archaic maybe it's just simply a kind of
mental thing where i still
maintain or i still have the mental
connection between how it feels and how
it looks and the xbox one which were for
me just
very difficult to use not difficult as
in i can't do it difficult as in like i
did not like doing it it felt bad to use
and i know there are people out there
who are like it's fine you know it's
it's it was usable it's fine you're just
moaning uh you know i respect that but
you're wrong um like it's it is it was a
trash fire and now that it's much better
it's
better but i would love to see them go
like hey we've we've completely revamped
it here here's a new one it's got less
of these nonsense things sticking out
like
when you click a button it's not 50 50
that is somehow going to take you to the
microsoft store or something like that
or open a browser or whatever it may be
i would love a bit a little more i'd
love to be confident in in the ui
experience a bit more if you know what i
mean it makes me feel old every time i
use it where i'm like what is this fun
press going to do what is this going to
do i've been playing games in my entire
life where is this going to take me is
it going to launch peggle or will i end
up like subscribing to
whatever the music service is currently
um
yeah well who cares
i think i think for me i think you both
bring up amazing points i think yeah
when they were
you know when they got all of those new
first party studios it was just like
okay well we have them now behold
my stuff behold my first party studio
yeah and it's like
it's very easy for us to sit here and go
oh well
when is stuff coming we need to know but
it's like
obviously the pandemic has shifted a lot
of things around and game development
takes years and so
it's it's just kind of
i don't know it's finding that balancing
act between dangling the carrot in front
of
you kind of the eyes of the viewers and
the fans and uh the players and stuff
but also you know
giving them a little bit give them a
little taste
just nibble it um because i think what i
want to see from xbox is i think they've
spent the last couple of years like
can't even underestimate the
180 that they've done and what phil has
helped them do
like after you know from the ashes of
don matrick
this new xbox that actually listens and
you know
writes the wrongs and
goes the way that people want it to go
right and so that can't be
underestimated or like
and so i i love the fact that they've
built up all this goodwill and now i'm
just i'm here for the games because like
the tech is is amazing i i love my xbox
i
just want to be like oh i i have to have
that game
that's that's the feeling that i miss i
am very very excited about halo i played
um and i'm not even like a big halo
person really but i played the the
multiplayer
multiplayer multiplayer multiplayer
multiplayer no that's uh
boulder's gate yeah that's the uh
mind player
i played the multiplayer test flight
lovecraftian event for halo infinite
where it's called multi-flair let's go
you can have that for free uh three four
three but now i played that and i was
like jesus christ this feels so good to
play even like just the sound effects
and stuff i i was like taken back to a
time just like playing in the game at
uni and i was like i want to feel that
way again about gears i want to i want
i'm very excited to see perfect dog i'm
extremely extremely interested in
red fall uh and as well star field and
elder scrolls and you know the fact that
they have this marriage with that's not
a marriage they own them yeah yeah they
have bethesda now and so you know what i
mean it's like i'm just i'm very very
excited about what the future's going to
bring yeah what we're saying is like the
age of phil spencer is over now it's
matt bowie's time to shine
where's phil spencer going
phil spencer what i'm saying is like
phil spence has done his part he's done
he's like he's now like passing the
baton off what we want to see is like
matt booty come in
uh mac booty and sarah bond just roll up
be like oh this is where we come in lads
we do it and big phil's like yes my
champions are here let's say if year two
of xbox hits what xbox has scheduled i'm
still not convinced that they actually
are but it kicks off with halo infinite
and then a few months later we get
stalker two in april and then a few
months later we get red fall in summer
2022 and then it ends year two with star
field on november 11th that'll be a
banger of a year too i'm still not
convinced that's going to happen but i
would love to be proven wrong yeah i i
don't think that happens but i think i
really i really wanted to i'm also like
one final quick thing is i'm very very
very interested to see what they're
doing with the cloud beyond xcloud
phil's spoken in the past about games
actually being developed in the cloud
and it would be way more impressive like
give developers way more tools to make
things that are bigger can have more
players in multiplayer for example so
i'm very very intrigued to see what
they'll do there but ultimately i think
year two for xbox is gonna be
a banger
so i think we'll leave it there
um jordan where can folks find you on
twitter
uh they can find me on twitter at jm
remai and tam him at tamor h
i'm at lewis james games we'll see you
in two days time because we're making
two of these videos obviously because it
is the playstation 5's uh one year
anniversary as well so make sure to like
this video and subscribe to gamespot to
see it and we'll catch you then bye
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you